weigh in on the situation
former acting director of ice and fox
news contributor tom home and tom
welcome
thanks for having me let's put on the
screen some numbers that really caught
our eyes from border patrol chief raul
ortiz
three-day recap
131 pounds of fentanyl 26 pounds of
heroin 13 pounds of meth 22 water
rescues 18 large groups totaling
2446 migrants 10 sex offenders three
gang members one assassination suspect
one fugitive wanted for murder three
agents assaulted extremely proud not of
all those bad things but of the effort
of his people no doubt tom what do you
make of those numbers well first of all
you know i wanted to say god bless the
families you're valuing my heart goes
out to them and 12 veterans who made the
ultimate sacrifice tomorrow day weekend
but look the numbers are astounding but
people need to understand that numbers
are going to get worse and the numbers
to get worse because this administration
to this day still hasn't done a single
thing to secure the border or take an
enforcement stance now they're going to
they're appealing the title 42 decision
by the judge this administration wants
to end title 42 and when that happens
the number of got aways we got well over
750 000
aliens across the border weren't
arrested and made into united states we
got over a hundred thousand overdose
deaths and that's gonna get worse
because when they lift title 42
that's going to cause more borders
agents be pulled off the line to process
people and release them which is going
to cause bigger openings on the border
which is going to mean more drugs are
going to get by the board of joe more
people are going to get by the border
joe and that's a huge national security
issue right now god bless the men and
women in green down there they're
seizing a lot of drugs might guarantee
you a lot more is getting away than
they're seizing and that should scare
every american that we are a long ways
from having this thing addressed when
you hear those numbers all those pounds
of drugs 22 water rescues just over a
three-day period
what kind of exhaustion does that lead
to in terms of the men and women there
on the front lines
well the men went bourbon
they're overworked they're they can't
contain what they had several chief
patrols that told me they have lost
operation control of our southern border
think about that for a moment the united
states of america does not
does not control the southern border the
criminal court tells them and why do i
say that because they can't contain
what's coming across that's how you get
750 000 got aways that's how you get
enough drugs to kill 100 000 americans
just last month they had 70 000 people
across the border that weren't arrested
and that's based on camera traffic drone
traffic and sensor traffic and
when some
what's really the most concerning to me
is administration keeps putting more and
more resources down there to process and
release quicker because you're more
concerned with the objects of the crisis
than the crisis itself and then you
understand when you process and release
quicker that's just going to bring more
people to the border because they're not
going to be detained in the second
ticket of the administration the next
two weeks is going to start doing asylum
interviews on the border they don't have
to know what they no longer have to go
see a judge they're going to have a cis
employee does it which is going to
result in more releases more approvals
and right now almost 90 percent of
central americans who claim asylum at
the border never get released from us
course they simply don't qualify they
don't show up in court nine out of ten
but this administration doesn't want
nine out of ten to lose their case they
want them to stay so they're changing
the rules or on the sideline that alone
is going to also bring more people to
the border because they're going to know
their chances of getting assigned are
going to increase substantially i worked
in texas for about 10 years early on in
my career and all the border patrol
people i knew
did not back away from a fight they were
there to do their jobs and do it to the
best of their ability but when they see
these overwhelming numbers and things
just going from bad to worse do you
worry about brain drain do you worry
about them just burning out and saying
you know what i just can't do this
anymore i'll do anything else
absolutely look i started my career
wearing a uniform
i was proud to wear that virtual uniform
i talked to hundreds of organizations
their morale is non-existent but god
bless these men and women they still put
it on the line every day for this
country they still put that uniform on
and come to work now the retirements are
sky high a lot of people are resigning
because they feel like they can't do the
mission they can't uphold the oath they
took to to enforce the walls on the
border borough's not used to processing
recent people in the united states that
entered illegally they're used to
processing people they want to have a
court case detain them
get a decision from the judge mostly
lose and they and they're deported back
home but under this administration
orbital agents are acting as tourist
agents one more two legends through a
friend of mine said after 30 years
wearing that uniform he now looks in the
mirror he feels like he's a part of the
biggest criminal alien smart smuggling
organization in the world because this
government is complicit and alien when
you cross the border illegally you're
not going to be detained you've got to
be held accountable you're going to get
a taxpayer funded airline ticket to go
to the destination of your choice
even if they show up in court and get
order removed no one's looking to remove
them because ice has been decapitated so
the board places morale in the toilet
but those men and women keep putting
them online every day for this country
i'm proud of that as one of them but i'm
also proud to say that i'm going to
defend them to the day i can no longer
breathe in this earth because you're the
greatest or the greatest mortal agents
well said tom homan thank you so much
for your time take care sir
thanks for having me